well the dollar loan center arena is
making sure everyone gets in on the fun
by opening its first inclusive sensory
room mary jane belliesa takes us to
henderson for the unveiling
it's the first room of its kind in
nevada the dollar loan center arena in
henderson unveiled its sensory room to
the public this weekend with the goal of
providing a welcoming space for guests
with autism or other sensory
requirements the facility teamed up with
culture city a non-profit focusing on
sensory accessibility to make it come to
life once we established a location we
had the size dimensions we sent all that
info to our team of occupational speech
behavior therapists along with
physicians and they plan out the
different elements that go in the room
we all have eight senses not six so our
sensory rooms really cater on six of
those eight senses the two that we don't
touch on are smell and taste that's just
because they're so subjective you talk
about allergies can't really get rid of
smell quickly from tactile walls to
fidget toys the dollar loan center hopes
this new room will give families more
opportunities to enjoy events at the
center while still providing those with
sensory needs for both adults and
children folks now know that the sensory
room is located at section 12. we also
have an app on our phone so families
beforehand can look and see where the
sensory room is where they can check out
sensory bags with the courtesy sign
employees just ask you limit your time
to 10 to 15 minutes for everyone to
enjoy the sensory room everything inside
is also sanitized after each use mary
jane belliesa live local now